και εκεί διαεκεί δημειουργείται μια εντύπωσης ι οποία δύσκολα αλλάζει η προσωπική εντύπωσης που δημιουργί
ένας άνθρωπος γνωρίζοντας έναν πολιτικόν πρόσωπο με πρόσωπο αν τον κερδήσεις εκεί ότι θέλεις πέσ
του παρακατο εκείνου του ψηοφόρου εγνώρισε το θυσέαν για να μη λεμε να άλλά ονόματα
και ο θυσέας τον εβοίτευσε τω έπισε ρα αυτός οψηφοφορώς ότι αρνητικών και να ακούσει
για τ θυσέα να βάλει που το ένααν αυκάλι που το άλλο αν ακούει και
διαβάζει τα καλύτερα για το θυσιαν αλλά στην προσωπική του επαφή με το θυσέαν εφγε
μέσι με μια ξυνήλα στο στόμα ότι θέλεις πέα του καλό δε θα ποιατο στα
πρόνοθησας να θερωσω για τον πρόεδρο χρηστο δουλίδι θεωρίσε των είνι πρόεδρος μία σητίας να
πα όπίσω στην απάντησημπουσ έδωσα για το κοσιοκτώ προηγουμένος ότι μεσολαβούν πάρα πολλα πράγοματα θεωρώ
ότι δεν μπορεί κάποιος να λέει ότι ονίκος ριτο ίκοσικωσία πέτε ριαχρόνια πριν ότι ο
χριστοδουλίδης είναι μία σθητίας ο εκείνοση που κατέχει το αξίωμα σε όλες τες χώρες είναι
εκείνωσε οποίος έχει σε σημαντικό βαθμόν και το προβάδιςμα δότι ξεκινά είναι στην εξω έχει
την εξουσία στα χέρια του έχει χίια δύο εργαλία τα οποία μπορούν να λειτουργίσουν υπέρτου
αρά να το βάλω διαφορετικά αυτή που προθούν την ιδέα εότιο χρηση το δουλίδης είναι
προεδροσμίας θητίας ε χατήρι του χριστο δουλίδι που κάνουν διότι στην πολιτική των ναπερνάς σε
κάποιο βαθμό να παρατήρητος να μέσα σα υπολογίζουν δεν προσών έναι πάντα κάτι το αρνηλικό
ναι αλλά ει το παρακολουθήσει το πολιλικο σύστημα χρόνια τι θεωρίσε ότι παλιλάχο σεσαγολικά και
στην εξωτερική πολιτική υπθήσης είναι απιστευτες το λενε όλοι στην εσωτερική πολιτική τι πάλιλάθος ή
καωςα κάνουν δεν βγαίνουν σωστάέξω προς τον κόσμο